I've spent a lot of time pro athletes we
go to one of his games
won't say the sport with one of those
games
we're sitting in the family section
because I know there's guys he's like
here's some fat you can go into the
family sections me and my wife in the
family section and the family section is
like right at where the action is we're
like literally we could probably high
five if we reach over enough right right
two girls are in the front row I know
who they are but they look good
and they're yelling at him now imagine
this hey
well together you and us
and he's just like he hears it right so
imagine you're a man okay you go to work
you go to work I don't care what you do
you're in town you show up at the office
yeah and two of the hottest 22 year olds
you've ever seen show up at your office
where you work hey we want to double
team you today what do you think
what would you do as a man it's like
that's just the life that he loves I've
seen this